we are two weeks away from the start of
the new school year for ccsd but are
students ready
data obtained by eight news now shows
just how much the covet 19 pandemic
and distance learning has impacted
grades kate houston has that breakdown
and what families can do if their child
is falling behind
my son has always been a straight a
sometimes b
student often receives
many recognitions many awards i've
always been a very proud mom
lorena yamas is busy preparing her son
hector for the upcoming school year
like many others hector struggled with
distance learning
i'm starting to see missing assignments
and you have a d
as a quarter grade and it's like wait a
minute
this isn't you this isn't right you're
not this type of student this data from
ccsd shows second semester grades from
the last school year
nearly 51 percent of middle schoolers
received at least
one f that's more than double what it
was the previous year
it was 40 percent for high schoolers and
31 percent for elementary
it is a real issue
that students have lost out on a lot of
learning in the last year and a half
rebecca shearer owns cultivate academics
she recently hired tutors for grades k
through 12 due to so many students
needing help missing one of those
foundational concepts
really then kind of created a domino
effect for some of our students
shearer says parents need to contact
their teacher directly if a student is
falling behind
they may need private assistance if it
continues
reach out to someone who has that
content knowledge and who can really
fill in those gaps right away
who can understand what the student is
actually struggling with what concepts
and dial into that
shearer hopes ccsd will provide
additional tutoring at the start of the
year
yamas thinks this will be crucial for
students like hector who didn't retain
information last year i don't want him
to
feel like he's struggling because he
doesn't know the material i'm hoping
that teachers will do that
kate houston 8 news now if you're
interested in getting an in-depth look
at all of that data head to our website
at 8newsnow.com
and don't forget you have until thursday
to help gather supplies for our great
school supply drive we're collecting all
sorts of school supplies for valley
students
ahead of the first big day august 9th
you can
drop off donations at any smith's
location through this thursday